hey guys what's up today's the first day
of e3 and I'm super excited is right now
we're kicking it off with the first
press conference of the day it's the
xbox press conferences we're here the
Galen Center I'm with Matt there's Matt
let's get this day started
my granny are a knockout on stage right
now they're playing across my prizes we
are stay down here this looks like a
good spot to start construction on my
mad scientist's lair Xbox 1s projects
will be a mat what do you think what is
a tariff bed console looks so great to
be on holiday 2017 that's a really long
time wait sorry Matt what was your
favorite thing I need to be honest with
you I can't stop thinking about oculus
minecraft I'm pretty excited about the
minecraft realms because I was doing it
a little bit in the Minecraft 10 beta
and it slightly still great to put a
light on Xbox on Windows so I don't have
to worry about transferring my worlds
back and forth try and play with my
friends although is the hardest part
just he's been trying to get me to do a
Minecraft series with her forever but we
just can't seem to get our stuff
together and get a server started what
do you think about the Xbox arena I
think it's very crucial that they
executed correctly and it and it works
the way it's supposed to work I guess
logistically I need to know more about
it yeah it's gonna be interesting they
didn't give us much details so I think
it's going to be one of those things we
wait and see it's also going to be
interesting because
focusing a lot more on certain sports
games I think we all know what we're
saying without really saying it
cross-platform pollination
all right ten minutes see you later
here's the problem this new camera that
we got the battery life it's awful I
have a handful of batteries and now I
got to go grab another charger so I can
charge the one in this one this Dean
what are you doing I'm vlogging my
tomato soup Matthew our video series
those look loose on your rings are
though I had to get it on they look so
good in 4k bro right has anybody on
YouTube ever uploaded a 4k on earrings
hour I've burned my tongue so bad on
these History Day
Metheny me the Yard House I'm like sweat
everyday now your fourth time today
lunch was delicious but now I'm full and
uncomfortable we're now heading to the
YouTube live studio here to do our
little live something we're never really
sure what we're doing but I believe
already be watching the Ubisoft press
conference and then chatting about it
hello Justine how are you good who are
you with uh I are small hey I was gonna
say
yeah okay so is this a big moment for
you here yeah we're about to head on to
the YouTube live show Jeff is doing 12
hours of live coverage this year why
don't you I don't know oh it's going
good like Jay we are live here at the
YouTube and apparently there's dancing
happening if maybe some press conference
okay oh wow
three we just got that on the YouTube e3
live show how's it going it's going
pretty wrong just just a few like 10
minutes worth of talking but I thought
that we all provided really good
insightful commentary anything you're
super excited about these seen so far
and you all that will feels really the
only thing we got hands on so far so I'm
going with that until I find something
else would we'll keep looking
and then there's more crossover you guys
we've got one of the customized
controllers you can carve so we calling
it something special so this from the
Xbox design lab I talked about it a
little bit earlier and from the press
conference but it looks so good
and I told Matt that I was definitely
you know gonna be that stereotypical
girl and I'm getting a hot pink one and
I don't care Caulkins right you said
Matthew you're ruining my video anyway
check it out Mac and you I hate
you so much
we just got done at YouTube live at the
studios we had a nice little fun cameo
and then we walked the Ubisoft press
conference which was it was like seven
hours long it was the longest thing ever
but what good things did come of that
was due so hard game wait what's it
fractured but whole rise your butthole
spell fractured bu T WH o L it's just
they're very nice play on words yeah
they're they're sort I'm Carter yeah my
blood sure has draw
I can't think straight after you guys I
know you guys just sighs go to lunch but
now we're going to dinner so we meet
again Jesus and same waitress we're back
now at the yard house and thank God Mac
decided to come back here because I
forgot this bag if it had all of my
extra batteries in it and a quest bar
and my GoPro and I was editing sitting
here at the table and I said I think we
bag might be here the restaurant and
guess what it was whoo
first up we're back on the bus back
bucks off to PlayStation we made it
through security I felt like that was
TSA it felt like it it was the real nice
routine to crack down all right you made
it here to the PlayStation press
conference time for some fun I'm excited
because it's kind of crazy I feel like
we knew a lot of what was already going
to be announced this morning at Xbox
because there were some leaks the night
before so I really don't know what to
expect
near PlayStation I'm definitely hoping
for some VR announcements there was a
little bit with Xbox but obviously with
PlayStation I think they've got a little
more on the VR line
for
Oh Mike we just went up like 15 flights
of stairs just watchin on stream I'm not
not sure if I'm cut out for this we
should look the elevator know there's a
lot of people here holy moly
we are so far away
the show
I'm happy to announce here are you
making fun of me no I gotta get me a
camera because I just thought this is me
right here hey guys losing the
camera and that's so much easier like my
arm is tired I like this one
oh is that the 360 at the scene it's
real alright alright ready everyone
yep three q1 I'll send you the picture
that's why it's like the matrix thing
and you don't remember anything here but
I love this little sound it's so yeah
exactly
I'm gonna do this as well like cuz it it
we are about to dub to the PlayStation
VR experience I believe we're going to
be able to actually capture some of our
gameplay so here we go
second floor second floor yeah
let's go let's go let's go that's what I
say to Maddie when I run it look at this
Wow oh my god I have want to try
resident evil holy moley we just got
done playing a demo of Resident Evil on
the PlayStation VR it was kind of wild
they also filmed it and did a game
capture screenplay of it so I'm not sure
when we'll actually get that footage but
it should be really funny to watch I was
freaking out I played it for so long
it's been a while since I've really done
much in VR and I do tend to get a little
bit of motion sickness so I'm still kind
of adjusting to it because I sort of
just hopped into it and started playing
and was moving my head around a lot so
it's going to be kind of cool to see the
actual gameplay footage matched with
what I was doing because I got super
immersed in it and I kept getting scared
by the silliest things like a mannequin
fell over and that's what scared me Oh
crazy
Batman was sick yeah they're gonna love
it I was having a little issue with the
motion sickness too but it might just be
the demo I think the full game will be
really really cool it was really fun
what a crazy day is so much stuff happen
I'm not even sure what all happened at
this point so much time that I didn't
film but yeah that was the first day of
III there may be another part of this
video continued tomorrow or I may post
this just as it is I guess time will
tell
hey guys how's it going this is day 2
technically be 3-day 3 for me of III
things but I haven't even been to the
show floor yet I actually haven't even
picked up my badge yet so I'm on my way
to do that and then do a bunch of fun
stuff first up we're doing a Sony booth
tour and then I'm going to be on the
game slot show and then I'm actually not
sure what the rest of the day rules
golfer video game up here mafia 3 is
just so great you know endorsement right
here I was only with you all the time
you're amazing I'm thinking of us you're
it's awesome suit you taking pictures
yes I don't think I've ever been like
starstruck before like this but that boy
is right in front of me
that's pretty cool we just got a demo of
Detroit come Holman and it was actually
really really fun not which thing the
game looks sick I'm actually really
excited for that it's really cool you
can basically like make a decision based
on what you feel you should be doing so
like yeah there's a lot of moral
decisions you're gonna have to make so
it should be interesting
anyway we are here in the PlayStation
booth and let's see we can see lots and
lots of VR going on
there's revenue and that is actually the
demo that we did the other day at the
party so I did pretty much I think was
like 15 to 20 minutes playthrough of it
it was really fun but I get a little
motion sickness sometimes during the VR
what's up how we doin I J yeah I'm so
good I'm good you having some
PlayStation VR hair I think I'm gonna
skip the VR right now but yes it looks
really great it does look great it's
going good uh what if I I haven't seen a
lot actually I I just I Detroit is
really cool we just got a demo it looks
really cool yes yeah so that was good
god of war looks pretty good you guys
saw the press conference right yeah yeah
I haven't got a pick out word on the
show here game fathers Chris God look at
this how do I make this in my house have
a truck I will make it fit
I actually came over here to say hi so
high I saw you're looking at your phone
to like
yeah I was like who can I who can help
me find Jenna's people right here that
was what I was gonna do
how's it gone have you binarism yes I
will be over here tomorrow from my tour
Oh
the only thing I can think about what I
see see if these is a hundred thieves
see my new tat oh my god oh sleep that's
dude I actually was like what did you do
to your body
you look good with the tag should you
got a chance to check out too much today
at e3 but tomorrow is gonna be the big
day where I'm doing the Xbox boot tour
and as head of soar and something
super-secret special I'm so excited
about it
that video will probably be up separate
from this one or the one that I do
tomorrow or who knows I don't know I
can't ever plan so shut up I was sending
you those